hello freak [ __ ] but when you were
young a job when did you know that you
wanted to be a singer I don't think I
ever knew I wanted to be a singer today
do you know now yes
no no it happened so how long were very
recently I mean literally the last I've
seen yes in the last 10 years I would
lightly I'm really good at this actually
and I enjoy it and I guess this is what
I do for a living this is my thing in 10
the last 10 or 10 years so I'm not going
on with you like when stupid girl was
coming out well I felt like I'd stumbled
into that opportunity which I did and I
wanted to be first of all I wanted to be
a writer then I wanted to be an actress
and then by total default I was in a
Youth Theater when I was young and I met
this guy and he was like would you come
and play keyboards in my band for a
weekend because we've lost our keyboard
player and I joined the band and then I
just ended up being in that band for 10
years playing keyboards and doing back
of vocals I was quite happy I didn't
have I didn't harbor any ambition to be
a lead singer at all and then just a
billion and one things happened and I
ended up being the lead singer of this
very same band just so that we could
survive because we'd been dropped by our
record label for going to Berlin and
spending all our money on our record
advance on drugs coming back and not
have anything to show for it so the
record company dropped us but kept me
and so then I pulled the band in as my
band so we just sort of shifted all the
rules oh wow I myself as the lead singer
by default and then our very good drugs
oh it's mostly speed and ecstasy speed
how much money you're spending on speed
Jesus Christ I was at the Norton that
money that it was our entire next
advance how much was it I can't remember
I think it was something like a hundred
thousand pints what is that like a
thousand dollars sing American swear
Honor I think it's double that doubled
its two hundred thousand and double oh
I'm doing the opposite oh my god yeah I
don't know I don't know how we did it I
mean it wasn't all on speed and it was
alcohol and you know going I drink you
know drinking and partying and just
wasting time and in America we call that
going off we went off you guys went off
we went totally Oh
and I wasn't one of the the room that I
I was one of the silver ones Cement afar
I mean you know and I know I did my
share but by comparison I kept my [ __ ]
together but anyway we wasted our
opportunity there but by default became
a lead singer our video got played on
MTV and then I just chance from garbage
the garbage boys needed a singer and I
got hired and and so I always felt I
just fumbled into it I got off
so wow that's crazy yeah it's pretty mad
and then I never believed in myself for
my whole first half of my what I call
the first phase of garbage
[Applause]
[Music]